♪
...
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: TO THE
STUDENTS OF THE CLASS OF 2022
AND THEIR PARENTS, FAMILIES, AN
FRIENDS: WELCOME TO THE 321ST
COMMENCEMENT OF YALE UNIVERSITY!
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE GATHER TO RECOGNIZE THE
EXTRAORDINARY ACCOMPLISHMENTS O
ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE WORKED SO
HARD TO COMPLETE YOUR PROGRAMS
OF STUDY.
WE SALUTE YOUR EFFORT, YOUR
DILIGENCE, YOUR TALENT, AND YOUR
INTELLECT.
WE ALSO JOIN YOU IN EXPRESSING
GRATITUDE FOR ALL WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED YOU IN THESE
ENDEAVORS:  YOUR FAMILIES, YOUR
FRIENDS, TEACHERS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE YALE COMMUNITY.
IN KEEPING WITH THE TRADITION
THIS OCCASION, I NOW CALL ON TH
UNIVERSITY CHAPLAIN TO OFFER AN
INVOCATION.
SHARON KUGLER: WITH DEEP
GRATITUDE TO THE QUINNIPIAC
PEOPLE FOR THIS LAND ON WHICH W
STAND, MY BELOVED YALE FAMILY, I
INVITE YOU TO JOIN ME IN THE
SPIRIT OF PRAYER.
ALMIGHTY AND LOVING CREATOR, Y
ARE THE FORCE THAT LIGHTS THE
STARS, THE ARCHITECT OF EVERY
CELL, THE SOURCE OF ALL TRUTH.
WE STAND IN THE DAZZLING BEAUT
OF THIS MORNING AS MANY
EXPRESSIONS OF ONE LIVING
MYSTERY, A MYSTERY BEYOND ALL
TELLING.
WE WHO SHARE THIS BEAUTIFUL, B
ACHING WORLD, WE WHO LOOK AT TH
SAME SUN AND THE SAME MOON, ARE
A PEOPLE CALLED TO COMMUNAL
RESTORATION.
AS STUDENTS OF YOUR HANDIWORK
HAVE GATHERED HERE FROM
THROUGHOUT THE EARTH WITH
EXQUISITE AMBITIONS AND HAVE
BEEN BLESSED IN THIS PLACE OF
LIGHT AND TRUTH WITH THE FREEDM
TO LET THEM GROW.
OUR GOD OF ALL GENERATIONS, YO
ARE THE GUARDIAN OF WHERE WE AR
GOING AND WHO WE ARE BECOMING.
AS WE PREPARE TO TAKE LEAVE OF
THIS PLACE MAY WE EXUDE AN
INTELLIGENCE THAT IS INSPIRED B
JUSTICE, GUIDED BY TENDERNESS,
MOVED BY HOLINESS, AND ALWAYS
INFORMED BY LOVE.
FROM THIS MOMENT OF AWE AND
BEYOND, FILL OUR HEARTS WITH AN
IMAGINATIVE DARING, ONE THAT
STIRS US TO BECOME VIBRANT
LIVING EXAMPLES OF SHALOM, OF
SALAAM, OF SHANTI, OF PEACE.
TOGETHER, LET US SAY, AMEN.
PLEASE BE SEATED.
DEAN CHUN: MR. PRESIDENT, I HA
THE HONOR TO PRESENT CANDIDATES
FOR THE BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN
YALE COLLEGE: FOR THE DEGREE OF
BACHELOR OF ARTS, 861 IN
NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF BACHELOR
OF SCIENCE, 518 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: IT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF PENT UP ENERGY TODAY.
YOU THINK MAYBE WE HAVEN'T DONE
THIS IN A COUPLE OF YEARS?
BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I
CONFER UPON YOU THE BACHELOR'S
DEGREES IN YALE COLLEGE AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN BERKE: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF ARCHITECTURE: FOR THE
DEGREE OF MASTER OF ARCHITECTURE
, 73 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE MASTER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DESIGN, 4 IN
NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I CONFE
UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN
ARCHITECTURE AND DESIGN AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMI
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN PINDER: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HONOR TO RECOGNIZE GRADUATES IN
THE SCHOOL OF ART:  FOR THE
DEGREE OF MASTER OF FINE ARTS,
49 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION AND
CONFERRED UPON THEM BY THIS
OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I CONFE
UPON YOU THE DEGREE IN ART AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMI
YOU TO ALL ITS RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN BUNDY: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
DAVID GEFFEN SCHOOL OF DRAMA:
[ PLAUSE ]
FOR THE CERTIFICATE A
,  IN NBE  FOR THE DEGREE
OF MASI
NUMB >> D FOR THE GREE OF
DOCTOR OF FE AS, 3 IN
MBER.
TY VE BEEN COMMENDY
TH FULTY OF THSCHOOL AND
APPROVEDY THE CORPORATN.
NOW A Y BY YOUR OFCI
T TO CONFER ON THEM THESE
DEEES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORYESTED IN ME, I CFER
UPON Y THE CTIFICATE AND
DEEES
BY THE DEAN AND ADMIYOU TO ALL
THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CALLINGS.
DEAN BLOCKER: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF MUSIC.
FOR THE CERTIFICATE IN
PERFORMANCE, 3 IN NUMBER:  FOR
THE ARTIST DIPLOMA, 2 IN NUMBER:
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
MUSIC, 58 IN NUMBER:  FOR THE
DEGREE OF MASTER OF MUSICAL
ARTS, 38 IN NUMBER:  AND FOR THE
DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF MUSICAL
ARTS, 14 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES!
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: YOU'RE QUICK
STUDIES.
BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I
CONFER UPON YOU THE CERTIFICATE,
DIPLOMA, AND DEGREES IN MUSIC AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN KURTH: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF NURSING.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
SCIENCE IN NURSING, 114 IN
NUMBER:  FOR THE POST-MASTER'S
CERTIFICATE IN NURSING, 1 IN
NUMBER, AND FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF NURSING PRACTICE, 18
IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I CONFE
UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN NURSING
AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND
ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN BURKE: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGEMENT, 117 IN
NUMBER:  FOR THE DEGREE OF
MASTER OF ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE,
20 IN NUMBER:  FOR THE DEGREE OF
MASTER OF FORESTRY, 7 IN NUMBER:
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
FOREST SCIENCE, 2 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I CONFE
UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN
ENVIRONMENT AND FORESTRY AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMI
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DEAN CHARLES: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF MAGISTRATE.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION, 387 IN
NUMBER:  FOR THE DEGREE OF
MASTER OF ADVANCED MANAGEMENT,
56 IN NUMBER:  AND FOR THE
DEGREE OF MASTER IN MANAGEMENT
STUDIES, 151 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM -- >>
THESE DEGREES!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: A NICE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT, MR. DEAN.
BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I
CONFER UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN
MANAGEMENT AS DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN STERLING: MR. PRESIDENT,
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
DIVINITY SCHOOL: FOR THE DEGREE
OF MASTER OF ARTS IN RELIGION
, 70 IN NUMBER:  FOR THE DEGREE
OF MASTER OF DIVINITY, 59 IN
NUMBER:  AND FOR THE DEGREE OF
MASTER OF SACRED THEOLOGY, 6 IN
NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE D.
DEGREES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I CONFE
UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN
RELIGION, DIVINITY, AND THEOLOG
AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND
ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN GERKEN: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
LAW SCHOOL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTERS IN
LAW, 38 IN NUMBER; FOR THE
DEGREE OF MASTER OF STUDIES OF
LAW, 3 IN NUMBER:  FOR THE
DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF THE SCIENCE
OF LAW, 5 IN NUMBER, AND FOR THE
DEGREE OF JURIS DOCTOR, 206 IN
NUMBER.
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDE
BY THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AN
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION, I
SHALL ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I SHALL
CONFER UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN
THE LAW SCHOOL WHEN DESIGNATED
BY THE DEAN AND SHALL THEN ADMI
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
MEANWHILE, CONGRATULATIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN COOLEY: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
GRADUATE SCHOOL: FOR THE DEGREE
OF MASTER OF STUDIES, 10 IN
NUMBER; FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER
OF SCIENCE, 271 IN NUMBER; FOR
THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF ARTS,
255 IN NUMBER; AND FOR THE
DEGREE IN MASTER OF PHILOSOPHY,
436 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I CONFE
UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN THE
GRADUATE SCHOOL AS DESIGNATED B
THE DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL
THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DEAN VERMUND: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, 184 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I CONFE
UPON YOU THE DEGREE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEA
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL ITS RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN BROWN: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
MEDICAL SCIENCE, 104 IN NUMBER.
WHEN THEY SHALL HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
THE SCHOOL AND APPROVED BY THE
CORPORATION, I SHALL ASK BY YOUR
OFFICIAL ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM
THIS DEGREE.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
HEALTH SCIENCE
, 32 IN NUMBER, AND FOR THE
DEGREE OF DOCTOR IN MEDICINE, 98
IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I SHALL
CONFER THE DEGREE IN MEDICAL
SCIENCE AND DO CONFER UPON YOU
THE DEGREES IN HEALTH SCIENCE
AND MEDICINE AS DESIGNATED BY
THE DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL
THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN COOLEY: PRAESES CLARISSIM
CANDIDATOS AD GRADUM
PHILOSOPHIAE DOCTORIS, NUMERO
CENTUM QUATTUOR DECEM TIBI
PRAESENTO.
A FACULTATE PHILOSOPHIAE
ARTIUMQUE ET AB SENATU ACADEMIC
ILLUSTRI APPROBATI SUNT.
TE, DOMINE, ROGO UT EOS AD HUN
GRADUM ADMITTAS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: SECUNDUM
LEGES MOREMQUE UNIVERSITATIS
NOSTRAE, VOS AD GRADUM
PHILOSOPHIAE DOCTORIS ADMITTO,
VOBISQUE UNA CUM HOC DIPLOMATE,
IURA ILLA ATQUE DIGNITATES, QUA
AD HUNC HONOREM SPECTANT
CONFERO.
NUNC, STUDIIS FELICITER
ABSOLUTIS, EGO, PRAESES
UNIVERITATIS, VOS EX ANIMO IUBE
SALVERE ET VALERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PLEASE RISE.
♪
♪ THY PRAISE ALONE, O LORD, DOTH
REIGN IN SION THINE OWN HILL ♪
♪ THEIR VOWS TO THEE THEY DO
MAINTAIN AND EVERMORE FULFILL ♪
♪ FOR THAT THOU DOST THEIR
PRAY'RS STILL HEAR AND DOST
THERETO AGREE ♪
♪ THY PEOPLE ALL BOTH FAR AND
NEAR WITH TRUST SHALL COME TO
THEE ♪
♪ OF THY GREAT JUSTICE HEAR O
GOD OUR HEALTH OF THEE DOTH RISE
♪
♪ THE HOPE OF ALL THE EARTH
ABROAD AND THE SEA-COASTS
LIKEWISE ♪
♪ WE DEDICATE OUR LIVES ANEW
THAT LIGHT AND TRUTH WILL SHINE
♪
♪ THROUGHOUT THE WORLD, O GOD,
WE PRAY TO ALL OF HUMANKIND ♪
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: PLEASE BE
SEATED.
WE WILL NOW PROCEED TO THE
AWARDING OF HONORARY DEGREES.
THE 10 INDIVIDUALS WE HONOR TH
MORNING SERVE AS EXAMPLES TO
YOU, OUR GRADUATES, TO ENCOURAG
YOU TO ASPIRE TO EXCELLENCE, AN
TO VALUE THOSE ELEMENTS OF HUMA
CHARACTER THAT THEY EMBODY:
CREATIVITY, CURIOSITY,
DISCIPLINE, INTEGRITY, AND A
PASSION FOR PUBLIC SERVICE.
THEIR PRESENCE HERE ALSO HONOR
YOU, WHO GRADUATE TODAY, AND AL
OF US WHO ARE HERE TO SALUTE
YOU.
I WILL NOW, AS IS CUSTOMARY,
CALL UPON THE PROVOST TO
PREVENT -- TO PRESENT -- THE
CANDIDATE THE FOR HONORARY
DEGREES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
PROVOST STROBEL: MR. PRESIDENT
I HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT THE
CANDIDATES FOR HONORARY DEGREES.
FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
HUMANE LETTERS, IN MEMORIAM:
MADELEINE K. ALBRIGHT, DIPLOMAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JAKE WATSON, YALE COLLEGE CLAS
OF 2022, IS ACCEPTING HIS
GRANDMOTHER'S DEGREE ON BEHALF
OF THE ALBRIGHT FAMILY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: SCHOLAR.
.
STATESWOMAN.
STALWART VOICE OF DEMOCRACY.
COMING TO AMERICA AS A CHILD,
SHE EMBODIED THE AMERICAN DREAM
BREAKING BARRIERS IN HER
POLITICAL CAREER AND PROMOTING
HUMAN RIGHTS FOR ALL.
WITH STRATEGIC POLICIES AND HE
STATEMENT PINS, SHE GUIDED
PEACEKEEPING EFFORTS AROUND THE
GLOBE WITH COURAGE, CONVICTION,
AND FLAIR.
IN GRATITUDE FOR HER PUBLIC
SERVICE AND ADMIRATION FOR HER
LEADERSHIP, YALE IS PLEASED TO
CONFER POSTHUMOUSLY THIS DOCTOR
OF HUMANE LETTERS DEGREE ON
MADELEINE K. ALBRIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL: FOR THE DEGRE
OF DOCTOR OF SCIENCE: DREW
WEISSMAN, IMMUNOLOGIST.
WE REGRET THAT DR. WEISSMAN
CANNOT BE HERE WITH US TODAY.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: PIONEERING
SCIENTIST, DOCTOR OF
DISTINCTION: HIS EFFORTS TO
UNLOCK THE POTENTIAL OF THE
HUMAN IMMUNE SYSTEM HAVE
RESHAPED OUR LIVES AND HELP US
TO ENVISION A POST-PANDEMIC
FUTURE.
HIS DISCOVERIES MADE IT POSSIB
TO ENLIST MESSENGER RNA IN
VACCINE FORM, TEACHING OUR
BODIES HOW TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AGAINST INFECTION-AND LAYING TH
FOUNDATION FOR MEDICAL
INNOVATIONS STILL TO COME.
WITH GRATITUDE FOR HIS
GROUNDBREAKING RESEARCH, YALE
HAS THE PLEASURE OF CONFERRING
ON HIM THIS DOCTOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL:  FOR THE DOCTOR
OF HUMANITIES:  JILL LEPORE,
HISTORIAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: PUBLIC
SCHOLAR OF THE HIGHEST CALIBER:
IN YOUR WRITINGS, TEACHING, AND
RESEARCH, YOU ILLUMINATE THE
HIDDEN CORNERS OF OUR SHARED
HISTORY.
YOUR GIFTS AS A STORYTELLER AR
MATCHED BY YOUR DEFT NAVIGATION
OF ARCHIVAL RECORDS.
YOU HAVE SHOWN US THAT THESE
TRUTHS ARE OUR TRUTHS, PAVING
THE WAY FOR DIALOGUE AND DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING
VOICE OF VERITAS AND OF LUX, I
RECOGNITION OF YOUR INSIGHTS AN
INTELLECT, WE ARE PRIVILEGED TO
PRESENT YOUR SECOND YALE DEGREE
DOCTOR OF HUMANITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL: FOR THE DEGRE
OF DOCTOR OF LAWS: MYRON H.
THOMPSON, JURIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: AUDACIOUS
ADVOCATE AND LEARNED LEGAL
SCHOLAR, YOU HAVE MADE JUSTICE
BOTH A CAREER AND A CALLING.
IN THE COURTROOM, YOU
TENACIOUSLY DEFEND EQUITY,
LIBERTY, AND DIGNITY FOR ALL; I
THE CLASSROOM, YOU TEACH OTHERS
TO WALK THE SAME PATH.
YOUR LONG SERVICE TO YOUR HOME
STATE INSPIRES US; YOUR
COMMITMENT TO YOUR ALMA MATER
HUMBLES US.
AS A TESTAMENT TO YOUR IMPACT,
AND WITH UTMOST PLEASURE, WE
AWARD YOU YOUR THIRD YALE
DEGREE, DOCTOR OF LAWS.
.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL: FOR THE DEGRE
OF DOCTOR OF MEDICAL SCIENCES:
JEAN BENNETT, PHYSICIAN
SCIENTIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: TRAILBLAZIN
DAUGHTER OF YALE AND NEW HAVEN,
YOUR VISION FOR NOVEL
THERAPEUTIC TREATMENTS HAS
RESTORED VISION FOR THOSE WHO
HAD LOST IT.
SHIFTING PARADIGMS AND PRACTIC
YOU BROUGHT THE POSSIBILITIES O
GENE THERAPY FROM CONCEPT TO
REALITY, GIVING NEW HOPE TO
PEDIATRIC PATIENTS AND OTHERS
AFFECTED BY CONGENITAL
DISORDERS.
WITH ACUITY AND ACUMEN, YOU HA
SET OUR SIGHTS TOWARD A BRIGHTER
FUTURE.
MAVERICK AND MENTOR, WE ARE
PROUD TO PRESENT YOU YOUR SECOND
YALE DEGREE:  DOCTOR OF MEDICAL
SCIENCE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL: FOR THE DEGRE
OF DOCTOR OF SOCIAL SCIENCE:
ORLANDO PATTERSON, CULTURAL
SOCIOLOGIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: ESTEEMED
EDUCATOR AND TRUSTED ADVISOR,
YOUR SCHOLARSHIP HAS SHAPED OUR
PERCEPTIONS OF FREEDOM, SLAVERY
POVERTY, AND EVEN ATHLETICS.
YOUR INFLUENCE TRANSCENDS THE
ACADEMY TO MAKE A VITAL
DIFFERENCE IN STRENGTHENING
COMMUNITIES: IN YOUR BIRTHPLACE
JAMAICA, YOU HAVE HELPED TO
DIRECT AID AND ATTENTION WHERE
THEY ARE NEEDED MOST, FROM THE
SHANTY TOWNS OF KINGSTON TO
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WITH REVERENCE, JOY, AND MORE
THAN A LITTLE AWE, YALE PRESENT
YOU WITH THIS DEGREE OF DOCTOR
OF SOCIAL SCIENCE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL: FOR THE DEGRE
OF DOCTOR OF MUSIC: CAROLINE
SHAW, MUSICIAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY:
SHAPE-SHIFTING CHANTEUSE: YOUR
VIRTUOSITY AS A MUSICIAN IS
RIVALED ONLY BY YOUR KNACK FOR
CREATIVE COLLABORATION.
DEFYING CONVENTION, YOU HAVE
DRAWN ON DIVERSE TRADITIONS AND
INFLUENCES TO PRODUCE GENRES AN
MELODIES THAT ARE ALL YOUR
OWN-ORANGE AND EVERGREEN, BLUE
AS THE SKY, AND DEEP AS THE
NARROW SEA.
FOR OPENING OUR EARS TO SOUNDS
HERETOFORE UNHEARD, AND FOR
ENGAGING A NEW ERA OF LISTENERS
WE ARE DELIGHTED TO CONFER YOUR
SECOND YALE DEGREE: DOCTOR OF
MUSIC.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL: FOR THE DEGRE
OF DOCTOR OF SCIENCE: KATALIN
KARIKÓ, BIOCHEMIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: RESILIENT I
YOUR PURSUIT TO EXPAND THE
BOUNDARIES OF KNOWLEDGE, YOU
STOOD UNWAVERING AGAINST
CHALLENGES AND SKEPTICISM.
AFTER LEARNING OF THE MECHANIS
OF MESSENGER RNA, YOU KNEW THAT
ITS CAPACITIES COULD BE
CHANNELED FOR THE GREATER GOOD.
YOU STAYED THE COURSE, AND YOU
PERSEVERANCE HAS TRANSFORMED A
BELEAGUERED WORLD.
IN APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
LIFE-SAVING WORK, YALE IS
HONORED TO BESTOW UPON YOU THIS
DOCTOR OF SCIENCE DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL: FOR THE DEGRE
OF DOCTOR OF DIVINITY: KRISTA
TIPPETT, JOURNALIST.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: CONVENER OF
CONVERSATION: IN BRINGING
SPIRITUALITY INTO THE SPOTLIGHT
YOU RAISE OUR SPIRITS AND REVEA
OUR COMMON HUMANITY.
YOUR PODCAST IS YOUR PULPIT, A
THE WORLD IS YOUR CONGREGATION.
WITH WISDOM, CANDOR, AND
FEARLESSNESS IN BROACHING THE
BIG QUESTIONS OF MEANING, YOU
INVITE US TO IMAGINE A NEW WAY
OF BEING AND OF LIVING-ONE THAT
CELEBRATES OUR
INTERCONNECTEDNESS.
INTREPID INTERLOCUTOR, FOR YOU
FLUENCY WITH FAITH, WE RECOGNIZ
YOU WITH YOUR SECOND YALE
DEGREE: DOCTOR OF DIVINITY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROVOST STROBEL: FOR THE DEGRE
OF DOCTOR OF HUMANE LETTERS:
JAMES E. CLYBURN, PUBLIC
SERVANT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: CHAMPION OF
CIVIL RIGHTS AND PRESERVER OF
OUR NATIONAL HISTORY, YOU
GALVANIZED YOUR GENERATION AND
HAVE INSPIRED THOSE THAT
FOLLOWED.
BEGINNING IN YOUR EARLY YEARS
A STUDENT ACTIVIST, YOU HAVE
BEEN A CATALYST FOR CHANGE,
STEADFAST IN YOUR DEDICATION TO
BETTERING THE LIVES OF YOUR
FELLOW CITIZENS.
YOU HAVE WORN MANY HATS:
EDUCATOR, ADVISOR, LEGISLATOR,
ROLE MODEL.
HERO AND HUMANIST, WE WELCOME
YOU TO THE YALE FAMILY WITH THI
DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF HUMANE
LETTERS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
PLEASE RISE.
♪
♪ LET LIGHT AND TRUTH SUFFUSE
THE MIND ♪
♪ AND SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
SHADOWED HEART ♪
♪ AS WHAT WE KNOW IS REDEFINED
♪
♪ THROUGH SCIENCE, SCHOLARSHIP,
AND ART ♪
♪ OUR FOUNDERS KNEW THAT FAITH
REQUIRES ♪
♪ THE DISCIPLINE OF STURDY
THOUGHT ♪
♪ THEY TRUSTED THAT THE SPIRIT'S
FIRES ♪
♪ BURN BRIGHTEST WHERE THE TRUTH
IS SOUGHT ♪
♪ WE'VE LEARNED THE WISEST
PRAYER THEY PRAYED ♪
♪ WAS THAT "MORE LIGHT" WOULD
GUIDE THEIR WAYS ♪
♪ FOR WE, LIKE THEM, HAVE BEEN
REMADE ♪
♪ BY UNEXPECTED, SLANTED RAYS ♪
♪ SO LET THE GIFT OF GATHERED
LIGHT ♪
♪ PERVADE THE WAYS WE LEARN AND
KNOW ♪
♪ AWAKING WONDER AND DELIGHT ♪
♪ WHILE KNOWLEDGE, TRUTH, AND
WISDOM GROW ♪
♪
DEAN STERLING:  I INVITE YOU AS
YOU BOW WITH ME AS WE OFFER ONE
MORE BLESSING ON THESE
GRADUATES.
GOD OF MYSTERY, YOU ARE OTHER,
YET WE ARE IN YOUR LIKENESS:
YOU ARE BEYOND, YET YOU ARE WI;
YOU ARE IMPERCEPTIBLE, YET YOU
ARE KNOWN.
AS WE SEND THESE GRADUATES INT
AN UNKNOWN FUTURE
GRANT THEM THE VISION TO SEE T
DIVINE IN ALL
OPEN THEIR HEARTS TO RIGHT THE
INJUSTICES THAT WE HAVE NOT
OVERCOME.
ENLIGHTEN THEIR EYES TO SEE WH
NO ONE HAS PERCEIVED.
FOR THE JOY OF LIFE IN THE
PRESENCE OF DEATH
.
FOR THE THRILL OF EMBODIED COMY
FOR THE HOPE OF A FUTURE THAT
THIS EVENT PROMISES.
WE THANK YOU AND ASK YOU TO
BLESS THESE GRADUATES, THEIR
FAMILIES, AND OUR COMMUNITY.
AMEN.
♪